jess is that friend where it's like when
you're when you break up with your
boyfriend she's like yeah [ __ ] that guy
i never liked him anyways get back
together oh yeah he's the best thank you
guys
whatever you need bury him got you she's
like you need me to help you carry the
body right i know a place well you miss
him okay we'll dig it back up we'll do
it
[Music]
hello welcome back to big mood everybody
i am nikki limo i am here to introduce
the other members of our episode we have
a very special guest one of my longest
time best friends jess lazama what is up
everybody i'm so happy you're here i
haven't seen her in so long because we
moved and all this little stuff going on
and then there's gina darling hello
who's always special but i see her all
the [ __ ] time and she smells so good
guys thank you i smell her all the
[ __ ] television
um hey guys
how are you feeling today i'm good i'm
amped yeah you're ants i'm amped i had a
lot of tequila though last night so then
if i'm if there's any tequila coming out
of my pores that's what i said just like
my wrist it was just a special perfume
you guys are both like really into
perfume blessings bless you i have like
my morning sniffles every morning so
it's like i gotta wait for a little bit
to go away your little routine your nose
like we're on our morning routine yeah i
get that allergies morning congestion
yeah it's weird you guys are weird
oh it doesn't go up your nose yeah
darn it i knew i was doing something
wrong weird things you guys are into
it's anything the kids are doing now
no but you guys always smell so good and
i don't know i don't know how you pick
it out or do it i'm like that's just
amazing you have good taste thank you
yeah thank you
yeah you both smell like roses and and
baccarats
i know i like poker so
i picked it out just for you and me
um so jess we haven't seen you in a
while it's been a long time thank you
for joining us you've been on every set
that we've had on big mood i love them
this is thanksgiving
it's beautiful thank you
and uh you have been just kicking ass i
just i only see you online so like what
kind of freaking stuff have you been i
know you do like
every time i see you're like doing like
workouts workout stuff you do at home
workouts yep you're in a beautiful
relationship that's goals i die for my
girlfriend you have a beautiful freaking
daughter that's you i don't know how
you're the same age i don't know how you
did it yeah she's gonna be 25 in
november i'm going to be 26. that's
crazy you just like crazy or like an
amoeba and just split
the same age as each other
we just split off we're like twins yeah
we didn't eat each other in the womb
yeah yeah that's real long did you come
up we don't
know
your mom you and her you're just all
clones you're just like stamping each
other yeah we're copy and paste yeah
we're the original copy and paste i want
to do that how do i join the club you
are going to be copied we can all be a
version of ourselves right yeah
absolutely yeah i'll trade your version
the first week that i met jess my uh my
favorite thing to do that whole entire
week was to show my friends
guess what get
guess what they are guessing a picture
of her
they're like
and then like they're like oh that's
proved pretty are they sisters i'm like
no
isn't that wild
it's like a whole week like i'm just
like thrown in everyone's face i don't
even know who you guys are i love you
thank you but you know it's like we're
either going to be we're either 21 or
98. yeah you don't know
there's no spectrum yeah it's just like
one day until you're old yeah and then
your friend career you're very old yeah
you're like
this person was never young this is just
not never a baby that was never a child
they're like pigeons you've never seen
baby pigeons that's so [ __ ] true
right they're just they're like cheating
no why just to [ __ ] my mind right now
i'm trying to like post a show and just
[ __ ] my mind up
so we're basically pigeons yeah yeah
that's what it is i am baby pitching
your baby picture my baby pigeon is this
episode i'm sorry i'm sorry first
episode of the day
slowly pans into the eyes and you're a
pidgey yeah everyone's a pigeon now
we're starting a pigeon cult in here so
i think this happened before we
after we talked last um you went to
london i did there's so there's yeah
there's a lot of you basically rounded
up all my life updates so i'll just kind
of
give you the details dive in there um
still in a relationship with lacy so
it's coming up on two years i can't
believe that the time is blue by
i remember when you guys just got
together and i was like oh my god that
makes so much sense we're baby pigeons
um two years i
i think my third third time to charm you
know i've been married twice before yeah
oh man it is a charm i'm like uh who's
the one who comes up with all the
perfumes um
she's been married like nine times
chanel could be mountain i don't know i
don't know anyone else
is it is it i've seen laura
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
she made the perfume diamond
besides the point
i know is britney spears and then i'm
out i'm out
[Laughter]
you cracked me up
exclamation do you guys remember that
perfume
um i know it's a good one curve is a
good one curve
[Music]
yeah and their perfume is curved
speaking of gyms
oh yeah and i i am my own person you
guys
through that right yeah we do camps now
together on zoom because kovit is crazy
and who doesn't want to work out from
home it's the most convenient thing i
love your guys's workout too it's really
awesome it's high it's fast fun and
effective we are like the 1980s
infomercial you never knew you even
needed in your life
um and then last october when i saw you
guys last i had just come back from
london because
channel 4 which is a uk channel i'm the
mentor of a teen mom show so it's like
an episodic teen moms like 16 moms and
their six babies get to live in a house
together and i got to mentor them and it
was really emotional but so rewarding
um oh okay sorry
six teen moms not sixteen moms there's
only six babies like where the [ __ ]
is what's going on the babies what
happened to the babies every week one
baby gets thrown out like it was 16
months when they were a baby and then
they turned into a pigeon yeah
yeah
yeah you're totally right number 16 moms
six
teen moms
and there are six babies okay got it
that's a lot of teens and babies it
really helps with with uh uh punctuation
because if you know when you're like
it's time to eat grandma you're not
gonna eat grandma it's time to eat comma
oh grandpa grandma
but i don't
um and then i have some really big news
i don't know when this is going to air
but i'll tell you guys your family
we're moving
yes automatically you're a packers
family now i'm sorry to your mom your
vikings fan mom i know because you're
going to be a huge packers fan nation
yeah i am i mean packers nation yeah
[ __ ] i'm really pumped i'm ready to um
build a life and not keep up with the
lifestyle yeah and i feel like that's
what you know i'm going to be 41 next
month shut the [ __ ] let's break the
internet this is what i'm talking about
please go on to the youtube channel
right now and view this woman visually
and then play it back where she goes i'm
41. what the [ __ ] like in what world i'm
a baby penguin remember i want to be a
big one i love you guys
oh my gosh asian don't raisin yeah yeah
but it's it's that thing where when
you're in your 20s and your 30s you
really can just
figure it out and mess it up and be away
from family and grind it up right well
if it doesn't work yeah i'm gonna try
again and then you'll fix it over and
over again um but now i want to be
closer to family and i want a house and
i want to have
generational wealth yes to pass on to my
daughter who's gonna be 25 in november
and it's just really hard to do in l.a
unless you are a trust fund baby yeah
and which i'm not so
yeah i mean even my most successful
friends in la i'm like they still like
it's still a grind it's it's a person
it's still like a lot of work and i'm
like you know
i just rather kind of live like i'm
retired in a different state absolutely
and you know what i respect that so much
because i think to have wealth and to
have a home in la is such that is such a
level of such an achievement it is such
an achievement because and i don't want
to be house porn if we bought a house
here
there'd be no vacations there'd be no
eating out like i would just have a
beautiful house i mean yeah like it's i
our condo we sold it
and was able to buy like a huge house in
vegas but like that's you can only buy a
condo here in in la for that price and
now you have a mansion in vegas yeah
it's really big i'm like
sometimes i walk around like they let me
live here where are the parents
when are they coming home
because i want to have a party yeah
and there's something i don't know if i
talked about this with you but i talked
about it with nikki where
when you're younger
you're okay being away from your family
because you're like i'll visit them and
i've got time and then you get into your
40s 50s and 60s and you're like oh my
god my parents are like 90. i need to go
home yeah i need to be closer to my
family if you're close to your family
because some people their family is very
triggering and they're not close yeah um
lacie is very close to her family and
they're absolutely incredible so i'm
really looking forward to pivoting out
and then we'll come back yeah you know
the goal is i want to
buy and sell homes and
have homes on both coasts and when
they're moving like snowbirds totally
see you doing that too like you were
just like the most
like i don't know like i want to buy
[ __ ] from you like i just like you're
you're so good at like telling me all
the good things about something and
thank you um like i'm like i don't even
wear perfume but i'm buying all the
perfume
i'm gonna do it because just you said
she's 41 and she looks like that and she
wears that perfume and then i can be
that i love you guys and i have to tell
you i really appreciate the way you guys
responded to that because i feel like
some people that we've told and we
haven't told many people respond in a
way where you me it makes you question
your own decision and then i said to
lacy i'm like people will only respond
in a way that how you give them
permission to respond to you and if
you're excited they're going to be
excited for you and if i mean we are
really excited but there has been some
people who are like wisconsin oh and
we're like well we have roots there oh
yeah that makes sense
but yeah the fact that you have to
justify it is is odd yeah just be happy
for me yeah exactly because you made a
choice and it's like you're happy you're
excited i don't i don't know i feel also
that people in la are a little bit
different because
hardly anyone's like from here and a lot
of people come here to build something
like some dream like it's like where
you're in the entertainment industry or
music industry or like anything that's
like a big industry that it's kind of
hard to make it in but like you want to
do it and be here and do it you're in
this grind it's sometimes it's hard to
fathom that there are people that are
over the grind and they're doing
anything else or that they would want to
do anything else and so when you're in
and i was in there too i was like yo why
why like you're in la though like you're
building something here like why would
you move i when i was in it i saw those
people and i was like i guess they gave
up or something right you know but now
being on the other side i'm like oh
there comes a time where you just think
wow i'm way happier over here actually
absolutely and you grind it out and you
grind and grind and like i'm really over
the grind yeah for me in my personal
career as doing fitness and hosting and
like working with brands and being an
influencer
i i'm at the top tier of the money that
i want to make here without going back
to what i was doing 10 years ago yes i
don't want to go and audition for 10
hours a day and work on 15 sets a day
lacey's at the top of her game like she
wants to go out as michael jordan yeah i
mean and in her industry in what we do
fitness your body is your tool yeah and
there's not i don't know how much longer
i could we could use our body to do what
we do i never thought of it that way
it's a lot we teach you know sometimes
two classes a day and which sounds like
nothing but that's two hours a day
three days a week and we work out six
days a week so it's like
you know it's so much energy and we love
it but
get out while you're on top yeah
you won't miss it you've done what you
can and i don't want to have regrets you
know have you guys ever thought about
like you know there's a lot of like
courses and stuff i'm sure you guys have
thought about this but like since you
are like okay we don't know how much
longer with our bodies you know you just
make a bunch of videos at once sell it
as a course and then it's like you're
frozen in time at this body level
absolutely yeah we have a virtual
platform perfect where there's boot camp
so it's like two weeks four weeks eight
weeks so you could see us every day for
the rest of your life and we will look
just like this perfect
i love it on the video games just like
that you can do like the virtual world
side where you guys can create your own
characters
there for vr classes
put on maybe we'll do that yeah some
metaverse fitness you can build a world
in there where you can build what your
gym looks like on the inside i like it
music you can yeah so and everything's
virtual now you guys yeah so if there's
anything that we need to do we can do it
virtually
it's virtually possible it's virtually
possible yeah
so those are the exciting things in my
life that's so exciting thank you i love
you guys thank you that felt really good
to like get off yeah like i feel like
everyone's kind of like moving into this
new phase or at least an art circle
maybe it's an age group thing i don't
know but it feels like everyone's
starting a new chapter in their life
yeah where gina's like on her tv show
now
i'm in vegas with steve you're moving to
wisconsin tiff just had a baby yeah like
she's going into a the brand new phase
of motherhood also so exciting
um yeah i wish she was here about the
teen mom thing because you guys were
both teen moms i love her i think we've
talked about this episode before this is
a girl yeah we miss you and jess is and
she's just as an accountant or you're
like a real accountant
i'm sorry like you're an accountant oh
she's an accountant
she got a cpa license whoa this [ __ ] is
working at a firm she's an adult yeah i
want to be an adult right i don't but
yeah
like she's like she's arriving at it i
feel like i'm a fake adult like i'm like
okay i collected adult things to pretend
with
i collected a house and i'm not i'm
playing house with the adult things
but yeah um it's it's fun and you know
when you're a kid you're like oh people
in their 30s they're adult adults and
i'm like wow this was what we were
looking at like this was the age person
well because when you're like 20 someone
tells you they're 40 and you're like oh
[ __ ] you're gonna die soon yeah
right
right oh man i hope you live your life
because uh you're going down your
retirement's coming up yeah and now at
my age i'm like
i feel like i'm in the i'm in the prime
and you know who you are yeah every year
you just get more settled with who you
are i think that's it and it's the best
thing and i never used to believe people
when they were like oh my god 30s are so
much better than 20s or 40s are so much
better than 30s you get it yeah right
yeah they're trying to compensate but
i'm like oh
cause like you know yourself and you're
like not insecure and you like have
self-esteem at that age and you got
money and money yeah yeah and you know
how to use it and you build something
and totally you know like you know how
to invest it you knew how to you know
how to
[Music]
like good you have a community of
friends like yeah that's really
important um and i was just listening to
a podcast about this but you know in the
beginning i feel like you're all about
like building your career and money and
like building something and that's great
because you need that but i
kind of thought like that was the big
game and then then everything else is
kind of like a you know accoutrement you
know
it's like on the side you know you get
to enjoy the other things you know after
you have the money but as i get older
i'm realizing how important
relationships are and how like that is
actually has actually been more valuable
and is more valuable than the money has
ever been it's so valuable that when you
don't have money or you don't or if
anything gets wiped away or someone
tries to take it away you have those
relationships still or hopefully you do
and i luckily do and i'm realizing that
wow like i would be nothing without that
that's your foundation yeah and you will
all your health
your health and your relationships man
health is wealth and as you get older
your physical health you're like whoa oh
this [ __ ] is important yeah i should
drink more water and take my vitamins
we're actually talking about there's an
episode we're doing with you a little
bit later about
things that older people would like to
tell younger people yes i have a lot
there are quite a few so tune into that
episode yeah i'll get on my mom's
soapbox for that so i just did that on a
shoot the other day everybody on set was
in their 20s and i'm like let me tell
you so i'll save it style icons don't do
it alone and neither should you if you
need a hand finding pieces that make you
look good then stitch fix has got you
covered whether you need date night
dresses or cozy loungewear stitch fix
can help refresh your look you can
schedule a fix and a stylist will send
you five pieces that fit your style size
and price range with no subscription
required keep what you like and return
the rest or if you like to shop but
don't want to endlessly browse then
check out stitch fix freestyle it's an
online shop built just for you it's like
having your very own clothing store to
get started take a style quiz so stitch
fix can learn your preferences from your
favorite colors to preferred fits and
price ranges it's the easy way to get
items that are just right for you from
brands you know and trust like madewell
and sanctuary it's time to get looks
that are so you so get started today by
filling out your freestyle quiz at
stitchfix.com
big mode and take advantage of free
shipping and returns that's
stitchfix.com
bigmode to try stitchfix stitchfix.com
bigmood sometimes in order to go green
you have to go blue blue land that is
blue land was founded on the belief that
a cleaner planet starts by eliminating
plastic waste while creating powerful
effective cleaners for your entire home
blue land's idea is simple and beautiful
buy the little bottle once refill it
forever no more plastic waste the only
thing you need to discard is your
outdated idea that eco-friendly products
are more expensive and less effective
just fill blue lands beautiful
instagramable bottles with warm water
pop in one of the hand soap or spray
cleaner tablets and within minutes you
have a powerful cleaning product in the
most incredible sense such as iris agave
purine lemon and lavender eucalyptus
from their best-selling clean essentials
kit to their hand soap duo and the
plastic free laundry and dishwasher
tablets blue land has something for
every inch of your home and back by very
popular demand is blue lands toilet
tablet cleaner get it before it sells
out again blue lands stunning high
quality forever bottles start at just 10
when you buy a kit and are meant to be
reused forever with money saving refill
tablets that start just at two dollars
try blue land today you'll love it and
the planet will thank you i like blue
lamb because it's such a unique look and
and way of approaching cleaning products
i think it's so cute i don't keep on
throwing out plastic bottles and buying
new ones i just buy these cute little
tablets and pop them in there it makes
me feel like i'm doing something for the
world right now you can get 20 off your
first order when you go to blueland.com
big mood that's 20 off your first order
of any blue land products at
blueland.com
big mood again that's blueland.com
big mood i can't even like
remember my 20s
like i'm so you know how people ask your
age i don't know if this happens to you
but people are asking my agent and i'm
like i have to think about it yeah
i know i know i'm 30 at least
like when people say like oh yeah back
in 2002 i'm like yeah 10 years ago yeah
yeah right
back in 2002 10 years ago
flashback from the 2010 music
sorry my cats just [ __ ] [ __ ] up right
now nibbler can you chill
these young kids you know walking around
playing with lights
what did you say earlier that i loved i
walk so that you can run oh yeah i walk
so they can run
you check them out like the gaming
industry yeah cute
i like how he has to like walk across
everyone to make it know like yeah get a
pet from everyone and then he leans his
body stretches out he's like feel my one
belly i told jess i was like this guy
owns the house and he will let you know
yeah and he does he will let you know if
i could have a cat like this i would
love a cat he i call him the gateway cat
people don't like cats love him and then
all of a sudden they're cat people he's
so snuggly
he's a guy he's a good way
he's like
hey you're a dog person not no mom yeah
yeah i know i'm a cat dog
i'm a penguin
so how is corrine um your daughter you
you guys are besties and is she moving
with you to wisconsin so my daughter
corinne's gonna be 25 in november that's
[ __ ] nice it's wild i've seen this
girl
when she was a baby she was 12 years old
not even a teenager yet
what it's absolutely wild we are besties
for the rest and she's not coming with
me she's going to flex her independence
and stretch and she's either going to be
here
with five roommates as you do in your
20s yeah or yeah
or
you okay over there bud
he fell in a box i can't fall into
boxing sorry canada she's just doing
something
things and
um and she's gonna she's going to school
and she manages the store and so but i
told her quit your job bop around i have
family in tennessee come with us in
wisconsin
joe's in baltimore like figure out where
you want to be and what you want to do
yeah
now
you know yeah yeah figure i'd say figure
it out first before going back to school
actually like decide on something and
then go back to school take three months
off yeah a month in each place yeah i'm
gonna tell her that because now's the
time right and like don't work to just
pay rent like we have to i told her you
have to do more than just survive
and that's really hard to do in your 20s
like having a goal in mind yeah yeah and
like now is the time when my family's
open to it
you're such a good mom though i feel
like you have given her all the tools
that she will ever need to like make it
in the world thank you because i'm
having a meltdown i'm like oh this is
your first time it's the first time i'm
leaving her ever in her life yeah can
you believe that yeah ever yeah
crazy
okay so just to break it down like jess
you were like
16 16 when you had her so you guys were
babies together together like basically
children having children and so you're
this is like your best friend you've
known you've all you've been together
your entire life yeah basically
and now it's the first time like oh my
god that your baby is going to spread
her wings and fly and me too for any
parent but for you especially because
you you're so young yeah it's like she's
letting you spread your wings too yeah
i'm i'm leaving the nest yeah and
in the byproduct of that is that she's
gonna have to leave the nest too
and i know that i've armed her like i've
armed her with all the information but
to have to sit back and watch her apply
that is really scary for me because i'm
like i just wanted to know i'm not
abandoning her yeah you know nobody got
enough to talk about therapy like i
don't need to add anymore to the pot
um
so yeah how does she feel about it
she's excited for me yeah she was like
mom i'm really proud of you she's like i
mean every thing i've ever told her in
life when i introduced her to lacey
because she was like the first person
that i told when i told her moving to
wisconsin and she was just like i'm
really proud of you you're really brave
i want to be like you when i grow up
thank you i do too i i love her so we'll
see what happens with her i'm confident
she'll figure it out but it's definitely
like how old were you guys when you guys
moved out of the house 21 19
okay yeah was it scary oh yeah yeah did
you have roommates um so yeah i did have
roommates
and then it was it was like it was very
interesting having to
learn how to pay bills yeah yes oh you
know what's the hard like is the toilet
paper toothpaste yeah your parents
always pay for it and then you think
about it they're like you just live in
the house they're not in the house yeah
exactly what do you mean we don't have
toilet paper you don't have a towel yeah
i have to buy a bath towel great and a
trash can yeah yeah my first bed was
from my friends because they were like
this married couple they're like oh
we're buying a new bed i'm like can i
can i have your old bed no like it's
like usually people are like ooh old
beds i'm like no i need you yeah i need
a bed because i'm on an air mattress on
the floor yeah it's like your animal
crossing house yeah
for [ __ ] ever yeah like
grow up
have my bed
it's true but like learning how to pay
bills like i literally remember i don't
remember who it was but i asked someone
like how do you pay like you have to
write a check they're like you can do it
online like i had to learn all that and
then i had to learn like luckily we had
what are your bills right yeah
right and then so um what is it
just things around the house
and then food like food's [ __ ]
expensive it is so expensive to be human
especially in this day and age yeah i
can't imagine like the people just
moving out right now where the inflation
like this crazy and i used to like oh my
god and you sound like such adults like
inflation i used to hear like things
like this like the inflation and
the gas prices yeah but now i'm like oh
yeah that [ __ ] hurts your bottom line
like
crazy like everyday
base level of living is like so much
higher than when i moved out because i
moved out during the housing crash so
everything was dirt [ __ ] cheap i
didn't feel that way i was like this is
expensive but now it's like peak
everything and we just tallied up what
her living expenses would be between
rent utilities food gas and it's twenty
five hundred dollars so
she has to make clear
double that yeah yeah at least they say
triple that but like triple that but
they'll double it because otherwise how
she gonna live she's not gonna be able
to take away any money for herself if
she can't make more than that and who at
24 makes five thousand dollars yeah
exactly yeah that's right so it's crazy
it's pretty wild hence i said girl
job or family
family yeah potato anything you can do
to like save up money yeah first
build a nugget a little nest yeah you
know
and then go out when you're ready too
yeah i wish i could move back with
family i feel so stupid for moving out i
should have never left
it was so cheap and there was food
people cooked i don't regret moving out
yeah i uh i feel like my dad and i were
like
too much the same person and we both
like to be
in charge of our own lives and like if
i'm under his roof he
made the rules so we've never had a
better relationship since i moved out me
and my dad are so much closer now like
we're like this and i'm realizing more
and more how much we're like because
when people used to say that i was like
no i'm not i'm not like him
and now i'm like oh my god we're the
same i find myself saying the same exact
things he used to say to me when i lived
with him and i'm like [ __ ] how did i
become in that's crazy but i get it now
um and so i don't regret that but i do
uh
i do miss when i first moved to my steve
we lived in a haunted house a [ __ ] i
remember this place oh god i shared a
wall we shared a wall with a funeral
home everyone
and i don't give a [ __ ] if you believe
in ghosts or not i don't i'm not saying
i saw a ghost i'm saying i cried every
[ __ ] day i lived there and i lived
there for a year and it was like you
wake up crying you go to bed crying i
can't stop crying why
i thought i thought it was me i thought
i was just like wow i've had depression
for a while but maybe it's like just
really bad now but i don't understand
because i'm really happy in this
relationship and everything's fine yeah
so i don't get it and every day you walk
outside and there's people mourning all
right right next to your card
and there's just dead bodies all the
time excuse me ma'am can you move your
civic i know your husband just died
can you move i gotta go i wanna go
somewhere i'm late yeah can you get out
of my car move yeah you can cry over
there
it's a nice little tree
they're like pairing the casket i'm like
oh
[Laughter]
i cry every day
it was the worst but it was 400 each a
month oh wow
that's great yeah and i'm like every
time i think back at those days i'm like
dude we could be [ __ ] loaded yeah if
we just stayed there this entire time
that's true it would definitely win our
happiness which is ultimately more
important don't get me wrong but i'm
like wow that was that was the life that
was a life
that eight hundred dollars for an entire
place is magic a month yeah yeah yeah i
think i might deal with the ghosts
right i couldn't but um i wish i wish i
could have i wish i could just like
sometimes and this is what they say like
sometimes they say that like certain
scents or like spirits or whatever i
swear to god nobody [ __ ] smoked
around that
complex but sometimes in our kitchen it
was like
crazy heavy cigarette smoke wow crazy
like all of a sudden cigarette smoke and
it was coming from one cabinet and there
was no
vent around there nothing but sometimes
a [ __ ] spirit that smoke decides to
smoke in my kitchen
yeah and i was like
and i would cry around it so i was like
you know what i'm gonna go it was a
crematory you were smelling bodies
getting burnt that's what it was
true
[Laughter]
baby penguins yeah to burning pigeons
pigeons yes oh yeah baby what did i say
penguins
which we have seen jess those do exist
okay those are really cute and maybe you
are a baby penguin yeah
that reminds me of something that was an
inside joke i don't even i don't know
where we are in this episode but one of
my favorite things about you is the [ __ ]
those baby skunks
there were it was a nice wedding it was
the night before my wedding they're so
cute but
my bridal party was there it was late we
were drinking and um they were
apparently the cutest baby skunks anyone
has ever seen like five of them
and everyone was freaking out of them
and i didn't get to see him nope and i
was like i didn't get to see him with
those dealerships
and i started getting emotional because
it's like it wasn't about the skunks so
yeah about the all the stuff yeah but
she took me inside and she was like
[ __ ] those baby skunks
that's what i looked at those babies hey
look at me [ __ ] those babies did you
hear me you listening to me are you
looking at me don't [ __ ] those babies
you don't need them
you don't need them
and she was like no yeah you're right
this is so upset i didn't get to see
them
i was like you'll [ __ ] those babies and
that's something you cry that's a good
yeah that's why she was my maid of water
yeah
how dare they make nikki cry how dare
they jess is that friend where it's like
when you're when you break up with your
boyfriend she's like yeah [ __ ] that guy
never liked him anyways get back
together oh yeah he's the best and yeah
i knew you guys would be together
[ __ ] him i told you something yeah
whatever you need marry him got you
she's like you need me to help you carry
the body
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
my door at 3am with a shovel i'm going
to just usher you in close the door and
find the duct tape
yeah
that is the girl that's the one you need
in your corner and that's what i'm
saying relationships are everything
who's gonna help you bury your body okay
they say that your mom knows she's gonna
rat you out
good friends help you move best friends
help you move bodies
oh this is there you go i like this and
this is coming from gina it's the this
is like the ultimate source of if any
knowledge about this subject were to
exist
that is the source you know what the key
is for her [ __ ] gun
oh my god it was so funny i was i was at
work and we have like this fabulous gay
guy at work in um in our show his name
is xander and then xander and i were
sitting in the makeup room and he just
looks at me he sheepishly goes
hey i was wondering um does that key
mean anything i was like
oh i mean no not really he goes oh
because
in the queer community it means that
you're a top and i was like
and then now it makes sense to me
because i remember someone tweeting at
me at my at my selfie they were like hey
is that key when i
means what i think it means and i never
responded i was like that's weird i
don't know like that i have a gun safe
yeah right so i was like no i no
it's just for my gun my trigger lock he
goes oh well now you know and you're
like how dare you i'm a bottom
so apparently um the tops were the key
and the bottoms were a lock around their
neck oh yeah
that uh wow i used to wear a key around
my neck as a child oh all through
elementary school um because i was a
latchkey kid
and i just thought it was a cool thing
to do like this is my house
i had a lock and a key because supposed
to give one to a best friend and yeah
and i didn't have a best friend at the
time i was my own best friend
and i realized right now i have a lock
necklace that i used to wear for a while
too so who would like me too
i thought it was because it was a chain
and then it would like held together
with a lock
yeah well the meaning of life didn't
weren't you the one that said something
about the arm tattoo uh in an episode
the armband oh barbed wire no
uh i it's like i saw it in kink
community and i think it was i think it
was
confirmed but i'm not 100 sure that when
you guys see people with like a just
like a line tattoo around their arm
it's how deep they've gotten
they've they fisted
how deep they have fisted in an [ __ ]
yeah what yeah
wait do you go hold on right and then
you move yeah
and you're like okay
and you're like right there right there
all the way around
wash your hands
you just go straight or you wash your
hands like how do you yeah
okay that freckle right there okay
noted
the creak of my elbow right there
if i ever see someone one right here
it's just be like jesus christ
so speaking of marriage
[Applause]
um you were talking about possibly a
third marriage earlier this episode yeah
has there been talks what how what's the
there's been no proposal okay we're
taking our time that's good um but i
definitely we we have definitely talked
about it we definitely want to get
married i've seen you try on the wedding
dresses i did
tipsy wedding dress shopping you guys is
probably like my favorite pasta
dude it seems so fun i think you know
what it seems even more fun when you
don't have a wedding at the end because
there's no pressure like you have no
pressure gina you would really dig it
probably and if they need some black
wedding dresses or something oh
they bring you champagne
yeah it's a party everyone's excited for
you because it wasn't ex it was exciting
don't get me wrong when we tried on
wedding dresses like we wanted to secure
the dress we needed to secure the dress
and it was like everything's really
expensive and like a lot of things are
expensive and the dress is an extra one
and like i need a budget in my canon
also like i don't know what i'm doing
and it's also not just the dress it's
also the veil and the headpiece yeah and
then they're gonna like like alter it
and do all this other stuff you need a
bustle what the [ __ ] is that
where do i need it can i have another
glass of champagne no i only get one all
right cool i guess i'll just drink all
your birthdays
yeah it was stressful there's no
pressure it's so much i'm like am i
gonna fit into this by the time i'm
getting married what's the rules for
that yeah yeah yeah i returned it
what's the return policy on this yeah
if i get divorced can i return this
technically it's you guys's fault it's
if you're weighing but still yeah your
dress was stunning i [ __ ] love my
dress i wish i could wear it every day
it was so comfortable are you gonna have
it altered to be like uh yeah i always
like yeah i would alter it to like be
short because it's tight it's like slim
fitting and then low cut and i was like
i'll just make it short and then just
wear it on anniversaries there you go
you know and it's cute and it's in may
and i feel like that's like a white like
thing totally i don't know um but
i uh
i just haven't done that yeah it's time
you're like you have a house yeah i
think like you just don't think about
your wedding dress afterwards i never
thought i wouldn't think about it but i
did wear it in an episode of big mood
during the pandemic when we all were
wearing yeah oh that's not fun old
wedding dresses or something they were
all getting fancy getting fancy yeah and
you're like and this is my wedding gown
yeah me and for our wedding gowns i love
that though yeah yeah you should try it
tipsy wedding gown shopping just to just
just try funsies yeah just for funsies
we do love talking about it though it's
just nice to talk about it's nice to
talk about when there's no pressure yeah
cause like i would imagine maybe you
guys are focused on getting a home first
i want a house yeah i definitely want to
way more better roi for your thank you
money i think if you dump a lot of money
into a wedding great that's awesome
i personally though i would like to do
the reverse yes like i did that i dumped
a lot of money into a wedding and we
didn't have a house yeah and then we
went back to our apartment and i'm like
uh something here feels reversed
yeah you need to like if there's one
thing i could tell a younger generation
well this is going to be in the old
episode save it but
you if you could have the ideal
situation would be put all your money
into assets younger in life and then
have your that income like that passive
income coming from the assets pay for
the wedding yeah pay for all the
luxuries pay for the other things i
don't know why it's ass backwards in our
society
i feel like they do it on purpose to
keep people poor because they make it
seem like so important you've got to do
this
and it keeps people poor it puts people
in debt you start your marriage life
often debt you know the number one cause
of divorce is financial stuff absolutely
and it's like you want to start in debt
that's the worst thing you could do to
yourself it's so dramatic they made a
show about it it's like say yes
yeah do you remember this do you guys
know this one oh they the parents are
giving them money to either have a big
wedding of their dreams or to invest in
a home oh would you feel like would be a
no-brainer to buy the house but nine
times out of ten they go oh my gosh the
wedding
wow and then that's the thing is because
it's built from a young age it's an
industry i feel like i was lucky that my
so my parents got married on their lunch
break on a tuesday how cute
at the courthouse and go back to work i
was never
i was never raised to think about a
wedding being like this big ordeal or
anything i never thought about my
wedding at all i did think about like i
wonder who i'm gonna marry and i wonder
how they're gonna propose because i've
watched like disney movies and stuff
that's so practical though i never
thought about like
the wedding like like even when steve
proposed to me i was so over the moon
excited and then people were like so do
you know your colors and i was like
what for what like
you know for the wedding i'm like
i'm wearing white
[Applause]
i had never been to a wedding in my
adult life before my own wedding
so i had that's right expectation i had
did not know and then when people i
thought okay um it's gonna cost like
maybe a birthday party but doubles
because there's two of us yeah so the
most i've ever spent on a party is like
500 bucks so like a thousand dollars
that sounds like a lot of money to spend
on a day and i'm like okay a thousand
dollars
i could do that yeah and then they're
like okay so the dress is gonna cost
twenty four hundred dollars
you're like that's a little out of my
budget
[Music]
just
right
we're talking about the same thing right
like the the item of clothing they're
like yeah like but i asked for the low
budget obviously yeah yeah this is the
two super one oh my god i gotta feed
people so uh game plan changing we're
gonna ross yeah yeah and luckily like
thank god so uh with the bar was
sponsored by uh captain morgan that's
right shout out to captain morgan they
did a full bar um
they owned captain morgan don julio
yeah smirnoff they had we had an ice
luge and a dolphin
ice sculpture was beautiful it was on
the beach in santa barbara and i wanted
to get married in santa barbara not
knowing that that was actually a
destination wedding town
it was just my hometown so i just wanted
to get married my hometown but we did at
the courthouse and i loved it and we did
it our reception was not fancy at all
but it was like overlooking the ocean so
it was pretty tacos
yeah we did uh trejos tacos uh we did a
buffet style with like disposable stuff
my wedding coordinator were so confused
she's like you're not gonna pick out
napkins or like utensils
do you need chair sashes i'm like the
[ __ ] does my chair need to be dressed up
for i had cupcakes as the wedding cake i
just was
not really i did not know like that that
was this was a big deal and um my
photographers were like you're the
chillest bride we've ever ever worked
with i was just gonna say but that whole
that goes along with who you are like
you're very you're not high maintenance
you're chill you just want people to
have a good time i just want to have a
good time i just have time like make
sure there's good music good music
alcohol good food that's all i [ __ ]
care about no one's going to remember
anything else no i remember what color
the napkins were no and i want to feel i
want to feel pretty and i want you to
take pictures of it and that's and that
was really nice
remember that we did it that way because
there was never any pressure to have a
big wedding and when i see people like
feeling like they need all this they
need to have like the like the perfect
flowers and the perfect napkins and the
perfect centerpieces i'm like yo this is
i now know how expensive that is and
like
i wish that you knew
what happens after like that after
you're just gonna hate that you spent so
much on that one day yeah and
traditionally um i think you know back
in the day
the family kind of like paid for it like
each guest gave enough of a monetary
gift that it covered the wedding but
it's not really like that anymore like
you get a toaster and a blender and [ __ ]
but like you don't like no one's [ __ ]
covering your wedding and you're like
what am i doing with 15 toasters and
then also like okay let's say you you
uh don't want to buy a house well what
about the honeymoon like i'd way rather
splurge on a honeymoon than i would on
the wedding absolutely like a vacation
really like that's way more exciting
that's why what i've been saying because
i think this was before i met you but i
had a 30th birthday party yeah and i'm
good with that it's so funny and now my
wedding is just going to be a courthouse
wedding and i'm not going and that's
about selfish they're pissed off as gina
we're all looking forward to gina's
wedding because her [ __ ]
30th was so awesome and i'm like okay
imagine her wedding though and she's
like nothing like he's gonna have a
courthouse yeah
no do you want to get married one day uh
i'm open to it i'm not like oh we have
to get married but i'm open to it if
it's there it's there nice yeah dating
right now i don't know this okay no i
got out of a relationship in november
okay yeah and i'm just doing like all of
us are willing to pitch in just have her
be the bride and throw a phenomenal
party like just her walking down the
aisle with nibbler
the two of them
because on my 30th birthday i had a
funeral for my birthday so i had like i
sent out invitations and i told everyone
to wear black but like extravagant black
i think like celebrity like a celebrity
funeral yeah and then like but i showed
up in like an all red sequin dress and
we had like it was like the death of her
youth yeah the death of my youth that's
great
um and then like she had a magician she
had a alcoholic boba maker she had a
catered it was lit i had like a throne
and like a three-tier all black cake and
like an arcade also okay see that is a
wedding yeah that was my that's my
wedding to myself and my friends
basically i did that because i wanted
all my different groups of friends to
meet each other and have fun and get to
know each other i love that mingle you
know yeah and mingle whereas at my
wedding i feel like it's just i kind of
just wanted to be me my significant
other and just a very small core group
of people yeah and it's just the
ceremony and then we go grab something
to eat and it'd be cool like and then
after after that i was like this is
all i really wanted really so then and i
told them that i wanted just like a
small courthouse like your face selfish
no how dare you how dare you yeah
yeah we were already planning our
outfits our yacht outfits the yacht
outfit
the paris outfit the japan one
how dare her how selfish
so selfish
but yeah i i think that's fun i mean we
went to chipotle for our wedding that's
great because there was a long gap
between the the um ceremony and the
reception because we couldn't time it
right because we didn't know it to
reserve it way in advance we don't know
i didn't know anything about weddings
and so there was this long gap and so we
just went the whole wedding party went
to chipotle we went through the line and
all sat in chipotle
those are my favorite weddings yeah yeah
it's like chill it's great memories
because everyone's always sick of like
all the steak dinners or chickens all
kind of blend together after a few
weddings like somebody remembers [ __ ]
but then everyone remembers that wedding
that we all went to chipotle yeah
that's hilarious yeah the friends
outside the [ __ ] bus yelling
see and like i remember that just from
watching the video of your wedding
whereas i don't remember anyone else's
[ __ ] wedding at all like oh and then
we did a troll first dance except for
your wedding cake
oh my gosh
your first song yeah we sang
for our first dance we we recorded us
singing a song
and then we danced to it very seriously
they were so serious we couldn't i
couldn't handle it
oh no
so it starts out it's um it's a uh can't
help falling in love with you so it's
like oh
man yeah it's the real like version of
someone singing it it's not elvis it's a
i think it was the ingrid michaelson
version that we did and um and she's
like starting it's very beautiful but in
the second line steve comes in and takes
over and he's like take my whole
two
and then i come in on the chorus but i'm
like robotic because it's all auto-tune
it's like
violin
and they're dancing
so seriously and we're like crying and
we're like looking into each other's
eyes
and then at the end of the source they
did we're promoting our youtube channel
we're like everybody's listening right
now go subscribe to our youtube channel
leave a comment we're dropping a
christmas album in december but we're
still dancing to it the whole time i
don't know how you guys didn't break
doing that
like crying cracking up trying not to
crack up
i don't know how you guys didn't break
you were so serious to the very end
so did you know that poor sleep can
cause weight gain mood issues poor
mental health and lower productivity and
that sleeping less than six to seven
hours per night is linked to reduced
white blood cell count yeah your white
blood cells are dying in there you know
what you need them you need them to
protect your body against illness and
diseases and fight viruses all kinds of
stuff and if you're like reducing them
that's no bueno okay even for me which
i'm usually like an eight hour a night
sleeper i've noticed that as i get older
i get awoken easier throughout the night
or like half awoken where like i don't
get a completely restful eight hours of
sleep and so i wake up still feeling
tired uh well beam is the world's first
innovative functional wellness brand and
today our listeners get a special
discount on beam's sleep product dream
powder their best-selling healthy hot
cocoa so this is a drink that contains
natural sleep promoting ingredients it's
triple lab tested there's no thc and you
wake up feeling refreshed 98 of people
surveyed fall asleep faster when taking
beam dream and 99 of people experience
better sleep quality including uh yours
truly hello i absolutely love this
product it tastes good and also just
like makes you it makes you just feel
really relaxed before going to bed and
then you drift off into a just really
comfortable sleep waking up feeling very
rested i feel like i'm getting the good
stuff when i drink this before bed and
beam's nano cbd dramatically increases
your body's ability to absorb cbd making
their products the most effective in the
wellness space just mix dream powder
into hot water or milk stir and enjoy
before bedtime and if you don't love it
get your money back guaranteed i love it
i also love that it came with this
little handheld mixer device like
electronic i don't know what those
things are called the buzzy things and
it just like froths everything really
quickly love it it's really added to my
nighttime before bedtime ritual and for
a limited time you can get 20 off when
you go to beamorganics.com
big mood and use code big mood at
checkout that's b-e-a-m-organics.com
big mood and use code big mood for
twenty dollars off are you still
sleeping on cotton that means your
sheets are dirty cotton is an incredibly
wasteful thirsty and damaging crop that
uses dangerous pesticides and drains the
earth's water supply it's time to move
on to something cleaner softer and
better for the environment and it
doesn't cost a fortune introducing
edited bamboo sheets because bamboo is
better in bed
so i am usually a very hot sleeper i
wake up feeling like a whole furnace but
um ever since i got the attitude sheets
it's made it so much more comfortable to
wake up and i'm not a sweaty mess in the
morning attitude is made from the
world's first clean bamboo fabric
attitude sheets are softer than silk
sustainable as hemp and uses 500 times
less water than cotton sheets they're
also silky soft attitude sheets are
luxuriously silky and get softer with
every wash just ask the 15 000 customers
who gave these sheets 5 stars attitude
sheets are breathable moisture wicking
and hypoallergenic attitude sheets keeps
you comfortable all night long they're
also better for the planet clean bamboo
is responsibly sourced and made in a
closed loop system that recycles 98 of
water in the process plus all of
ettitude's products are climate neutral
certified try any attitude betting with
their 30 night sleep trial if you're not
completely satisfied return it for a
full refund right now you can get 20 off
your order plus free shipping when you
visit attitude dot com slash mood that's
e t t i t u d e dot com slash mood this
is attitude's best offer but don't wait
it's only for a limited time order today
for free shipping and 20 off your order
at attitude.com
mood having been to weddings after that
i was like oh that's how they're
supposed to go
oh [ __ ] oh whoa you're supposed to buy
that oh crazy
i'm really glad that we didn't know any
of that
because i definitely would have spent
all the money on it and um it's a lot of
pressure yeah it's a lot of pressure and
even like
afterwards because we still had our
apartment too and we hadn't bought a
house yet and um buying the condo and
then getting into home decor and like
all the you know color palette and like
really getting into it i'm like whoa if
i were to get married today i definitely
would have had a pinterest board and
like all kinds of [ __ ] and i would have
spent a lot of money and i don't think
that would have been the correct
decision
at that time in my life but like yeah i
could totally see i'm not judging anyone
because i could totally see
absolutely you would want to do that um
i just think wow i'm very thankful that
we were able to not know that and take
that money and spend it on
buying a house and still have the time
of your life at your wedding yeah
because you know any better yeah and
like really looking back it really ties
back into the whole thing of
relationships or everything and i'm
pissed actually the one thing i'm pissed
about is that like you weren't there
like none of the people that i actually
hang out with now
or were there or some of them were but
like
like a lot of the people that mean so
much to me right now in my life i'm like
yeah you weren't even there i know so
look at the pictures i'm like i wish i
could photoshop these people in there
but like in real life
they would they would literally be there
for the memories yeah and we didn't have
a lot of friends at our wedding um so
the ones that we did have um i was like
well these are like definitely life
really like half of them are gone yeah
yeah i just realized wasn't your wedding
an outdoor wedding it was outdoor for
the ceremony indoor for the reception
that's cause i was gonna say if the
reception was outdoor and there was just
people jogging by hearing that music and
just like
i think at my wedding really because
like in the video footage i'm like who's
who is that like the first people to eat
at the buffet like before anybody
weren't the staff
but they're just random people that are
they even dressed they're like wow this
is a beautiful restaurant no they're
like in casual clothes and i'm like
crashers wow definitely a real thing yes
that's a thing they definitely went in
there thinking they knew and they didn't
know and they're like we're eating yeah
yeah grab a cupcake
one first that's crazy huh yeah so
beware of that um i don't know that was
a real thing me neither i wonder if it's
like deliberate or there's lost tourists
i bet you it's deliberate some of them
are delicious some of them have to be
they
like that they like scout scope out
weddings yeah
i also there was a person
who storied that they crashed our
wedding like on instagram like i stopped
by
and then like i'm like that's weird oh
we also had a live stream that's right i
forgot about this steve wait who is this
person i don't know it's just a random i
just didn't acknowledge it because i
didn't want to i didn't want to be like
promote it or like that's [ __ ] weird
it was weird creepy
um and also like yeah i'm glad that they
weren't like a harmful person but yeah
yeah
don't brag about that that's rude um but
there was a live stream that was like
promoting
so steve on his channel then like months
leading up to that was like be sure to
tune on my live stream it's gonna be on
my channel like we're live streaming the
wedding because a lot of youtubers like
live stream their wedding like it's
gonna be at this time you know make sure
you're there and so we had the live
stream all set up and it was like in the
reception and then um you can see like
people walking by and like you know
there's youtubers at our wedding so they
recognize some people and they're like
commenting and stuff and then someone
goes oh yeah just put the presents over
there and so they put the gift bags
right in front of the camera over the
camera like it was the troll that steve
had been setting up and so there's just
like bags and like you can kind of see a
slime oh my gosh like the wedding and
you could hear people talking next to it
totally trolling them
it was the best
so they could see it but not see it like
this live stream oh you don't like it in
the beginning
she's a massive streamer um and she's
planning her wedding right now so she
decided to
stream herself like she usually plays
video games so in order to make money
for her wedding to to pay for her
wedding she decided to do
uh i think it was
she'll keep streaming so long as people
keep subscribing because every time they
subscribe she gets money to pay for a
subscription she's like
forever i don't know like for every 100
subscribers i'll extend the stream by an
hour she went for like 16 days holy [ __ ]
yeah
this was a wedding like themed no no
this was just her playing games
and then she'll go to sleep at night the
camera's still on and everything like i
think it was at least almost like two
weeks or so she's streaming because
people kept on subbing and subbing and
subbing how did you extend the time did
she sleep during the stream yeah she has
left it on the whole time and she made a
[ __ ] ton of [ __ ]
yeah but she made a [ __ ] she had to make
a [ __ ] ton of money off of it that's
crazy yeah that's amazing that's smart
how funny would it be though if they
were like we're gonna extend our wedding
so long as people keep subscribing
longer than an every wedding
time
again everyone's like
the kids
[Laughter]
my drunk uncle's still trying to take
off my
my face what's that called the garter
belt
i had a drunk uncle one of those yeah
clothes that like right
he just swooped and i'm like ew get up
he also ruined my cake topper he
just tried to steal it and he dropped it
in the road and i was like
cool that's cool he stole the cake
yeah the like you know how you're
supposed to save it for like a year or
whatever
yeah that's right
him and his wife were trying to steal
everything they were just like stealing
bouquets stealing did you confront them
did you tell them no
because like it was i didn't care that
much about my wedding but i did i was
kind of like that's rude also our um
events staff or someone stole all the
food oh my god like i wasn't going
to eat at all because you know you're
the bride and i barely got to have a
drink and i didn't get to eat at all
because i was talking to people the
whole time and so all i could think
about was like okay as soon as we
[ __ ] get to the hotel room i'm
scarfing those tacos
someone stole all the food there were
tons of leftovers too i kept eyeballing
it during the reception i was like oh my
god oh my god
taco yeah and then no then someone took
it people steal [ __ ] that's another
thing
you get ready people
people steal [ __ ] at weddings so make
sure you buy this centerpieces my sister
and i [ __ ] um like we're each other's
lookouts for our weddings yeah like we
have like drunken
family members that we know like without
a doubt gets drunk and shit-faced and
crazy at every wedding
so we have to play like security for
each other like whenever each other get
married we already have a game plan
okay so what do they talk about
everything yeah like they just they just
get [ __ ] face like one oh my god one
one aunt got married and the eldest aunt
while we were all having dinner the
eldest on grabbed the microphone and was
like
um i'll change the name but
ashley
i'm so happy for you you never brought a
boyfriend home we thought you were a
lesbian
and then like
that aunt the eldest aunt on the
microphone her kids were just like oh no
who gave this woman a microphone yeah
one of my bridesmaids did that
oh my god are you serious she was wasted
she put the
the speech on the phone
she had a speech she was trying to read
it and she couldn't figure it out so she
squatted in the middle of the dance
floor she said she was on the mic
because she's like i gotta read this
and i gotta sit down
and then she lost the spot and had to
she kept i i cut it out of the video it
was pretty funny in hindsight but uh oh
she also
shout out to jamie but she uh she dyed
her hair uh bright
blue and purple and i didn't know um
that you weren't supposed to do that so
i didn't think anything of it but people
were like you know
she's she's got really bright hair are
you gonna like are you gonna cut her out
of the pictures and i was like oh i
didn't think about that because they're
like yeah when you look back on pictures
that's all you're gonna that's gonna be
the thing that pops out
and i was like oh that's true
photography was really expensive
so we had her like be on the end of
everything but yeah it was that's right
there was a lot of things i didn't know
about right like wedding etiquette yeah
and um wedding etiquette
anything that could happen that was like
crazy aunts or uncles friends totally
did um crashers definitely did happen
but it was fine because i didn't have
expectations about it um we also uh my
one of the aunts the drunkest one that
was trying to steal [ __ ] with her with
my uncle um she went viral at my wedding
because uh tim delegato was dancing with
her and was like you know drunken with
the dancing with the drunk auntie at the
wedding and it went viral on facebook
and so she was like static she's like
she's famous she's like
dance moves
and silver wears porn out of her
personal pockets people are messaging
like isn't this your wedding and i was
like yep
yep that's my aunt
yep she definitely tried to steal my
veil yeah when my best friend was
getting married way back when when i
still had pink and purple hair yeah two
weeks before the wedding i kind of sat
there i was like i had noticed myself or
i thought to myself like oh [ __ ] i'm the
only one with bright colors and i didn't
know like yeah i don't think that's okay
you know because there's like i
so i kind of reached out to her i was
like hey do you want me to like
have a wig on or something so i don't
[ __ ] stick out like a sore thumb
she's like oh my god i didn't know how
to ask you thank you so much
i was like oh okay yeah no no i totally
got it and then that was the first time
i've ever worn like a wig i had to i
bought like a really nice brown wig i
had it styled from a stylus and
everything put it on
but this wedding was in the middle of
july oh outdoors here in california yeah
i was sweating like when i was sitting
like this there was sweat coming down my
thighs yeah that was the worst oh yeah
and then after the reception it was time
to dance i was like can i please for the
love of god take off this way she's like
yes no we we're done with pictures go
ahead you need to breathe yeah i just
need to breathe and i went and i [ __ ]
took that [ __ ] off and i came back and
people were like
who are you the [ __ ] are you yeah
that's fine
i'm at a wedding crasher yeah it's okay
we're fine
i belong here
so it didn't stick out yeah i never
never never really
yeah i did not know had it not been for
my bridesmaids who had been to weddings
before they were like yeah yeah you're
not going to want that i'm like oh yeah
that's true i didn't think of that
because it's just like i don't you don't
think about it in regular life i'm like
yeah everyone should express themselves
but yeah looking back in pictures it
would definitely have been the only
thing you see
it was like bright yeah very very bright
blue and purple i love embarrassing
wedding stories i wish we could have a
whole segment on that i know
embarrassing wedding stories we all got
them i had one on because uh vietnamese
chinese people love having like super
asian weddings and there's always a
stage with a karaoke i love a carrier
that's so fun i had one aunt that was so
drunk like she'd be done singing and
then she'll just climb off the stage
squat down just full blown [ __ ]
panties whatever just every time she
climbed down was like oh my god wow
we're getting the full frontal shot
there yeah
like and they all get shit-faced and
then they ever like my aunt threw up on
the table what the
you know like it was on the expensive
food yeah your family's a mess gina i
found these crazy like one side of my
make you look responsible yeah
completely like we all have a running
joke amongst all the cousins like the
younger generation we're like oh my god
our weddings are going to be [ __ ]
we're going to need security
this is going to be crazy people out
yeah because like every table hides
their own bottles of hennessy under the
table
and like i remember like my cousin when
she was a bridesmaid she came over and
she's like oh yeah she's pulled a
[ __ ] hennessy ball out of nowhere i'm
like that was magical one got locked in
a closet when i came home one uncle was
a half asleep like he was asleep half
his body on the floor half his body on
the couch my mom's passed out in a bunk
bed those are good timings yeah
someone's getting married time to get
[ __ ] up exactly like that's their like
that's their time to shine oh my gosh
those are good times and the person who
got locked in the closet were they
supposed to be in the wedding um i don't
know no i don't remember who it was it
was one of my cousins because that would
have been they found her in there they
just missed the whole wedding no it was
towards the end oh okay yeah
yeah it was another example yeah
weddings are the time well yeah i think
uh i think that you're gonna have a lot
of fun with your with your one w when
you however you guys decide to
when that happens because now you know
now i know and you're like it's gonna be
simple i don't know i just have a chill
time what i imagine just like a you're
gonna invite us like a workout class
and it just happens it's like an
aerobics wedding yeah
you guys are in the all white outfits
and we're just like dude
i love a themed wedding i love a themed
wedding i think um we always slide down
to a movie we always said because we
didn't get to invite all of our friends
to our wedding that like we'll do a
10-year bow renewal um and we'll like
make it really fun and like we'll
actually like splurge money into it and
i was like i've been thinking about like
what to do for it and i'm like we
definitely have to have a theme like
some sort of like themed wedding party
because that's just like if it's for
funsies yeah and you have the time and
money and like your friends are aware to
be there like let's just have a [ __ ]
blast when's your tenure
um it's in five years
well it's been five years five years i
can't believe that
what is time it's not real it doesn't
feel like it was like two years ago wait
it's been five years
yeah whoa
yeah we've been together for a long last
time too because we had a long
engagement and
it's been like 10 years together three
years of friendship like i don't even
remember not knowing steve to be honest
yeah
like we we came out of the womb together
i'm pretty sure
we're not related
you need each other yeah well anyway
that flew by
we are at the end now everyone uh i hope
you learned some things about how to
throw the proper wedding how to not this
was supposed to be a catch-up episode
how'd it become a wedding episode
we got we did catch up a lot with uh
jess's life but you can catch up more
about following her on instagram
youtube all of the places we'll put the
info in the description
is there anything you would like them to
go check out workout classes is there a
website oh yeah you can work out with us
yeah work out on zoom every tuesday
friday and saturday so you can literally
bust a move with us three days a week
i've done the work because it's so fun
and i'm like you don't think that it's
gonna
like be make you as like uh what's it
called like get you as fit or get your
muscles as sore you're like uh this
can't be
because it's so fun and then the next
day you're like holy [ __ ] my butt is
firm and i can't move my legs we
probably do like a thousand squats and
everything yeah like legitimate but it's
so fun like you're just not i just
didn't think i was getting as good of a
workout as i was actually getting this
girl can squat don't let her fool you
she's got have you seen the ball she's
got a dumpy she's got a kadunka it's the
it's the nicest you know you smack it a
lot i can squat i can't do anything with
my arms though these are noodles
her legs are so strong i would love for
everyone in the world to work out with
us just dm me just underscore the zama
and i'll hook you up yes let me know in
the comments uh what what you how many
weddings i don't know what i'm trying to
say just [ __ ] comment something i
love you catch up with that at this
point i'm going to put my cat's link in
there too because he's a cast meet now
apparently right he has an instagram and
he wants to know like what do you guys
want to know for him like can you
promote anything nibbler
nibble where can they find you we're
going yeah
he's like i want to go outside
let's see what's out in the world my
balls back
[Music]
you